transformando armas en Esperanza así se
llama la iniciativa de la empresa
productora de acero gerdaudia co que
cuenta con la colaboración del ejército
colombiano más de 28.000 armas
incautadas fueron donadas y fundidas con
la misión de enviar un potente mensaje
modificar los elementos que hacían daños
en las calles en herramientas útiles
son armas que están en poder de
delincuentes de diferentes categorías y
pelambres esas armas hoy se recogen y
una vez fundidas pasan a ser acero de
construcción que se va a llevar parte de
eso a vivienda de interés social
pistolas fusiles ametralladoras y
lanzacohetes entre otro tipo de
armamento son parte del proyecto de la
empresa que apunta a edificar casas en
el departamento de boyacá donde tiene su
sede central tuvimos la oportunidad de
contribuir con Colombia con la
destrucción de armas que fueron
capturadas por las fuerzas armadas y
donde nosotros transformamos estará
Estas armas en Aceros que nosotros
donamos para construcción de viviendas
para las personas que viven cerca de
nuestra nuestra planta desde 2018 se han
fundido alrededor de 180.000 armas en el
país
el ejército Se comprometió a continuar
colaborando con La Iniciativa con un
único objetivo llevar tranquilidad a la
vida de los colombianos